hey this is press tow
Walker here's an interesting question
that a lot of people are talking about a
mom stumped by her first graders
homework posted the problem online to
ask for help as reported by today.com
which word is the odd one out the
choices are friend desk toothbrush egg
and
silver explain
why I will say at first reaction this
question puzzled me because none of the
answer choices immediately jumped out
usually questions of this type are more
obvious look at this example of a
question which is the odd one out apple
banana cashew orange and
strawberry it seems obvious that cashew
would be the correct answer because all
the other choices apple banana orange
and strawberry are fruits or take a look
at this question 1 3 6 5 and 9 it would
seem obvious that six is the correct
answer because all the other numbers 1 3
5 and 9 are odd
numbers there are other justifications
but these are at least the obvious
choices so let's take a look at our
question again so I thought about this a
little more and ultimately I came up
with this line of reasoning I thought
that friend desk toothbrush and egg were
all nouns whereas silver I would usually
think about the color and silver would
be an adjective like that car is silver
so I wondered is my reasoning valid I
thought to ask artificial intelligence
after all models like chat GPT and
Google bard are based on large language
models so they were probably designed
precisely to answer this type of
language question so here's the answers
they gave chat GPT said the word silver
is the odd one out because it is a metal
while the other words friend desk
toothbrush egg are not Metals but rather
represent different types of items
Google bard said the odd one out is
silver here's why friend desk toothbrush
and egg are all concrete nouns that
represent physical objects silver is an
abstract noun that represents a concept
rather than a physical object therefore
silver is the OD and out because it
belongs to a different grammatical
category than the other words some
people put comments that all of the
other items are countable objects
whereas silver is an uncountable object
same
idea so what was the correct answer it
turns out silver was the intended answer
the class had just done a lesson on
nouns and silver being an adjective was
the odd one out but is that the only
possible answer do most people even
think that silver is the correct
answer I put a poll on YouTube and an
astounding 50,000 of you replied and
here are the results almost 50% of
people said that friend was the odd one
out this was followed by the choice of
silver at
23% then toothbrush at
15% egg at 11% and desk at
3% so what are the justifications for
these
answers I was not able to go through all
of the comments which were over 2,000
and I want to thank every single person
who provided a comment but I did try to
read as many as possible to understand
the explanations I will give a special
thanks to Javin Leong 3433 who
summarized many of the answers in a
comment so let's take a look at the
answer choice of friend why would friend
be the odd one out all of the other
answers are physical objects that can be
purchased or possessed on the other hand
friend is a concept that describes a
relationship between people you might
say that friend is something that you
cannot purchase or friend would depend
on feelings it's something that can
change as physical objects a desk will
be a desk a toothbrush is a toothbrush
an egg will be an egg silver is bound to
be silver but the same person can be a
friend one day and not a friend the
other
day next answer Choice egg let's take a
look at the number of letters in each
word friend has six desk has four
toothbrush 10 and silver six egg has
only three letters so if you look at
this egg is the only choice that has an
odd number of letters whereas all of the
other choices have an even number of
letters egg with three letters being odd
is literally the odd one
out toothbrush was also a popular answer
in a way toothbrush stands out because
it is the longest answer Choice it is
also the only word in the list without
the letter e which is the most common
letter in the English language it is
also the only word that's a compound
word because it is made up of tooth and
brush so there are good reasons to say
that toothbrush is the odd one
out finally we have the answer choice of
desk only 3% even thought that this
could be the odd one out so it's kind of
interesting that when we're going
through this list everyone 's like oh
yeah desk will fit in with this
categorization whatever they
thought but in that way there is
something different about desk all of
the other options have obvious reasons
for being the odd one out the fact that
desk jumps out to no one makes desk an
odd
choice but there's also a deeper
mathematical answer courtesy of James o-
yu9
SP so a square number is the product of
an integer with itself like 1 squar is 1
2^2 is 4 3 squ is 9 4 squ is 16 but why
is it called Square what does a
geometric Square have to do with the
square number the name square number
comes from the fact that you can arrange
a square number of points into a square
shape so we can have one as a square
shape 2x two 2 is 4 3x 3 is 9 4X 4 is 16
and so on so you could have this concept
for other shapes there's a similar
concept of a triangular number so these
are points that can be arranged into a
triangular array triangular numbers also
correspond to the sum of the whole
numbers going from 1 to n so they come
up frequently in mathematics so the
first few triangular numbers are 1 3 6
10 and there's a general formula of n *
n + 1 all over 2 so now let's take a
look at the number of letters in each
word again friend has six desk has four
toothbrush 10 egg three and silver
six so all of the choices are triangular
numbers except for desk which is four
and that is a square number so you could
say desk is the odd one out because all
of the other choices have a number of
letters that's a triangular number but
desk being at four is not a triangular
number of
letters so in conclusion I think there
are valid reasons for picking any of the
options and the important point is the
reasoning behind the choice rather than
just trying to select the answer that
was intended so I ask you what answer
would you have put
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
[Music]
time